نحن الان في معبر باب الهوى بين سوريا
وتركيا يشهدوا المعبر حركه اعتياديه
للشاحنات ما عدا الشاحنات التي تظهر الان
بالكاميرا والتي تنقذ المساعدات الامميه
الى داخل ادلب هذه الشاحنات كانت قد
استقرت في ساحه المعبر وكانت قد دخلت وفقا
اليه ايصال المساعدات السابقه الان تتحرك
الى داخل محافظه ادلب
لتستقر في مستودعات المنظمات الشريكه
للامم المتحده يتم بعد ذلك تسليم
المساعدات الى مستحقيها من النازحين ومن
السكان منظمه مناسبون استجابه تتوقع ان
تدخل المساعدات وفقا اليتي ايصال
المساعدات الجديده في غضون 10 ايام تصل
الى هذا المعبر ويتم نقلها بعد ذلك الى
محافظه ادلب لكن المنظمه تقول ان هذه
المساعدات لا تكفي لسد حاجات ومتطلبات
النازحين وخاصه في فصل الشتاء صهيب الخلف
الجزيره معبر باب الهواء ادلب